[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt ich bin ja gerade vollem putzfimmel
und möchte einfach das haus auf
vordermann bringen frühjahrsputz ist
angesagt in diesem video zeige ich euch
wie ihr schnell und einfach euer
badezimmer sauber bekommt ein paar tipps
und tricks zur abschluss reinigung und
natürlich auch tipps und tricks zur
reiniger selber herstellung sagt man das
so ich glaube schon denn ihr braucht
wirklich nicht viele reiniger zu hause
ihr braucht wirklich nur einen ganz
kleinen schranken kleinen vorrat und
könnt euch so viel geld sparen viel zeit
sparen und viel platz sparen
los gehts jetzt bei mir denn ich werde
zuerst einmal die schränke innen
ausräumen ausmisten und da geht es auch
den ganz einfachen trick lagert einfach
nicht so viel verbraucht eure produkte
auf bevor ihr neuer aufmacht das gilt
gerade bei shampoo bei krems dass ihr
einfach nicht so viel rum stehen habt im
badezimmer und kaufte wirklich nur
sachen die ihr braucht und die ihr
verwendet also ich fange jetzt hier an
wir sind hier bei uns im elternbeirat
und mein badezimmer
die kinder haben ein eigenes aber die
haben eigentlich kaum noch sachen die
sie brauchen nur die sind erst neun und
vier von drei grad ein bisschen
körperpflege und das war's und ich
starte jetzt hier vorne und dann eben am
waschbecken ausräumen ausmisten
auswaschen
ich benutze jetzt dafür meinen
allzweckreiniger den habe ich selber
hergestellt das findet ihr auch in einem
anderen video das rezept super einfach
und vor allem ganz natürlich und eben
trotzdem stark genug um alles sauber und
rein zu bekommen
ich fange jetzt hier bei mir von oben
nach unten an also erstmal hier diesen
schrank denen eigentlich größtenteils
ich also demokratie kaum post drin und
ich habe ihn natürlich auch dinge die im
alltag so liegen bleiben anfangen die
räume ich dann alles denken
[Musik]
ich habe ich eine box da sage ich jetzt
alles was ich aus satire was nicht hier
ins bad gehört aber was nicht
weggeschmissen wird durch sich dann
später woanders ein
zum beispiel so alte kosmetik typen die
benutze ich dann wenn ich das weiter
verschenkt und hier habe ich aber auch
noch an meinem putzke die der mülltüte
für dinge die eben sofort entsorgt
werden also leere schachteln ich glaube
bei monat werde ich doch ziemlich fündig
und einfach dinge die man nicht mehr so
braucht hier beim ihr seht ihr zum
beispiel ich habe immer nur ein parfüm
was sich aktuell benutze und habe
deswegen auch nur eine parfümflasche
rumstehen
ich zeige euch gleich weil morath das
gegenteil murat hat nämlich immer
tausende sachen rumstehen
aber ich finde wenn man eben nur eins
benutzt und ich bin eher so der typ ein
duft der mir eben steht und der zu mir
passt und alles andere
ich habe natürlich auch paar filme im
vorrat das habe ich dann bei uns in der
vorratskammer
wenn ihr aber alles im badezimmer lagern
wirst weil hier eben keine vorratskammer
habt dann würde ich einfach nicht zu
viel kaufen auf vorrat also habt
wirklich immer nur ein zweiter es könnte
dann hinten dran lagern gdingen dem
fahrrad sind die offenen und weiter
vorne und dann steht s bahn eben nicht
so voll und ihr habt eben auch schön
sauber
[Musik]
für meine kosmetik drin sind die kann
ich auch gleich austauschen
die nämlich heraus dass die die ich
gebraucht habe bin ich reinige die in
wirklich regelmäßigen abständen auch
gleich eine andere sind noch frisch und
hier räume ich dann auch immer mal
wieder alles schön raus kann hier meine
wechselgrund denn auch sauber machen
denn es wird auch ziemlich schmutzig
erinnern dass nämlich zeitung ist im
wasser du bleibst danach schön trocken
und hier habe ich alles so nach
kategorien sortiert also concealer mit
concealer pinsel und alles in der
reihenfolge wie ich es eben auch beim
schminken dann brauche ich meine pinsel
und die reinige ich dann immer so
ich habe hier im handwerk mittel einfach
eine ph neutrale seife damit kann ich
mir auch mein gesicht reinigung nehme
ich einfach ein bisschen was in die hand
und kreise den pinsel in der hand wie
als würdig farbe aufnehmen wie bei einer
wasserfarbe so wasserkasten bisschen
wasser dran und es wird zum beispiel ein
concealer pinsel da ist jetzt in mehr
farbe drin
das muss ich dann zwei mal ungefähr
machen zwischendurch mal auswaschen und
wenn ihr mal wirklich farbe habt die
nicht rausgehen will gibt es auch
spezielle pinselreiniger die habe ich
jetzt einfach beim dm geholt klar mit
sprüchen jedoch mal kurz zwischendurch
für die schnelle pinsel reinigung und
damit kriegt dann immer so allerbeste
noch aus da nehme ich mein handtuch und
lass die pinsel schön im leben trocknen
damit das wasser nicht hier unten in den
stiel rhein fließt am besten wäre sogar
so zu trocknen wenn ihr so ein pinsel
aufhänger hat ansonsten einfach im
liegen trocknen
[Musik]
die pinsel lasse ich jetzt einfach 24
schon trocknen und räumen sind dann
später dann sollte ich hier auch wieder
alles reinräume mein parfüm und hier
habe ich einfach und die dose das reich
der dose für unterwegs die räume ich
glaube ich zu meinen kleidern zu meinen
reisetaschen weil da kommt dann immer
schmuck rein wenn ich unterwegs bin und
dann habe ich praktisch gepackt regel
nummer eins ist fertig jetzt geht's
direkt unten drunter weiter und hier
arbeite ich einfach mit so einem bock
system aber ich habe hier ganz viele
regale das regal haben wir einfach
selber gebaut
alex zusammen und ich habe ziemlich
flache regal ist oder sich wirklich
immer gut dran kommen so ist alles immer
schon ordentlich ich habe hier oben zum
beispiel ein fön glätteisen und kann
jetzt auch alles ganz einfach
austauschen
[Musik]
eine solche boxen habt dann geht alles
so schnell
und das ist alles sportlich wie kann ich
jetzt gleich die tür innen und außen
auswischen und ablöschen und dann ist
der schrank fertig und es hat jetzt hier
keine zehn minuten gedauert
dann geht es hier unten weiter mit
meinem schrank da ist im prinzip alles
ganz gut sortiert weil ich hier auch
echt immer eine gute ordnung halte ich
habe hier auch viele kipping die ich
dann eben einfach rausnehmen kann und
kann jetzt hier aber noch mal über alle
produkte zu unterdrücken
wobei ich das echt die man regelmäßig
machen also wenn ich abends zähneputzen
morgens dann gucke ich immer was brauche
ich was brauche ich nicht und habe echt
nur wichtige sachen bei mir drin und
alles andere kann eigentlich weg oder
information gut ich habe ich so box für
dinge die ich gerade nicht sofort weg
räumen will schmuck zum beispiel oder
malen lippenstift oder eine halskette
und dinge die ich einfach öfter trage
deshalb ein kleines durcheinander
aber das kann ich jetzt auch kurz weg
sortieren
[Musik]
das hier sind übrigens zur organizer die
gibt es in jeder drogerie sind
verschiedenen größen und da habe ich mir
einfach mal angeguckt was ich so
brauchen könnte ist noch nicht optimal
vielleicht finde ich auch mal ein
organisierte noch besser zu mir passt zu
meinen lippenstiften aber ja momentan
tut seinen zweck dass immer alles drin
was ich so für jeden tag braucht
ich brauch nicht jeden tag so viel
lippenstifte aber ihr wisst ortsverein
oder weiß was ich meine
ok blitzeblank wittern produkte rein ich
auch nicht mal alle brauche jedoch dass
für das kommt jetzt ein fahrrad ein
gesichts erfrischung
ganz frisch ist es wahrscheinlich nur
wasser in der tasche refresh aber da ich
sowieso logo und so drin und irgendwas
was deine haut erfrischt also dinge die
frauen eben brauchen
ich hab ich so kleine boxen dafür gummis
und haarspangen
[Musik]
sich doch mehr dreck und als man glaubt
ja hab ich jetzt noch so meine
haarspangen drin meine riesen haare mies
kamm und bürste meinen schrank geräumt
[Musik]
ich zeige euch so etwas aber der
nachfolgende ausschnitt die nächsten
zehn sekunden könnten euch wirklich
schaden
ich übernehme keine haftung murat
schublade
das meine ich übrigens mit raps lieber
immer nur eins von jedem produkt da und
nicht so viele angefangene produkte
denen man verliert man schnell den
überblick der morath sammelt übrigens
auch diese hotel teile dies dort dann
als geschenk gibt die nehmen wir dann
immer meter schwabe ist ja auch ganz
praktisch ist ja ganz gut
die kriegt man ja da geschenkt aber die
kann man zum beispiel in reise schublade
machen ich habe nämlich bei mir im
hauswirtschaftsraum einfach so eine
reise schokolade wo ich die kleinen
teile sondern und ansonsten sehe ich bei
murat einfach drei verschiedene deos
cologna also desinfektionsmittel für die
hände ganz viel rasierer ganz mit
rasierklingen der schlaf der gut in
meinem selber aufräumen ja etwas befreit
ihn nämlich das macht ihn dann glücklich
wenn er das selber macht mit meinem
schrecken bin ich jetzt also fertig
statt da drüben noch eine kleine kiste
das mache ich das sind wir unsere
badewannen und so setzte und so drin
jetzt gehe ich als nächstes direkt mal
zum abschluss also dusche und zeigt euch
da bis zum abschluss vorbereitet wie ihr
ihn einwirken lassen könnt damit wenn er
verstopft ist eben schön frei wird
[Musik]
jetzt geht es um auch abflüsse ihr
braucht keine teuren rohrreiniger oder
abflussreiniger sondern wirklich nur
zwei zutaten das ist zum einen die
zitronensäure und natron jetzt könnt ihr
euch wirklich einen großen parks
bestellen das ist ganz günstig einfach
im haushalt lagern und ihr verzichtet
wirklich komplett auf die ganze
chemiekeule des ewr zu kaufen gibt ihr
könnt damit die dusche reinigen
abonniert den achtlos waschbecken
abfluss überall wo es verstopft ist und
nicht sauber ist könnt ihr wirklich
super damit rechnen hier mit hier
erstmal die abdeckungen weg die sollte
man auch regelmäßig säubern
wir machen das hier alle zwei wochen
sauberen weil es gerade bei so großen
duschen über diesen abschluss bleibt
halt echt gerne hier mal was hängen und
das solltet ihr auch machen ansonsten
wie ist bilden sich bakterien das kann
sich schimmel bilden und daher wirklich
weg die sport auf lassen jetzt im
gleichen teilen natron und zitronensäure
reingeben ich mache also vier esslöffel
der zitronensäure direkt hinterher
man hört auch schon bisher hier und hier
noch direkt heißes wasser dazugeben
nicht so viel ist oder nicht gleich
weggespült werden sondern einfach nur
miteinander reagieren
[Musik]
ihr könnt hier auch gerne esse ich
verwenden statt zitronensäure allerdings
ist ein bisschen besser
denn weder dichtungen habt gummi oder
auch kunststoffteile dann greift es sich
diese teile gerne mal an zitronensäure
ist zum einen geruchsneutral und einfach
ein bisschen schonender so gummi und
kunststoffteilen
deswegen habe ich die 2 marke und
schloss es ist hier noch kurz einwirken
und macht so man an einer anderen stelle
weiter als nächstes ist die toilette
drum die toilette wird bei uns jeden tag
geputzt das mache ich einfach im antrag
mehr wenn ich morgens auf die toilette
geht dann nehme ich sofort meinen
desinfektionsmittel macht die toilette
sauber und das finde ich gehört auch zum
täglichen alltag mit dazu was sich dann
noch einmal die woche mache ist innen
drin die toilette putzen
das mache ich jetzt jemand bei uns gibt
kohle eigentlich zum trinken sondern
eher nur zum putzen wenn ihr also eine
flasche cola übrig habt könnt ihr hier
drinnen die toilette immer ganz gut
reinigen cola löst zum einen kalk cola
löste borghorst urinstein und alles ich
muss sagen unsere toiletten sehen
eigentlich nicht so schmutzig aus weil
wir sind wirklich jede woche
grundreinigung hier innen drin und dann
nehme ich jetzt hier etwas cola und
natron denn beides reagiert auch ganz
gut und ich stelle auf gleich immer
unsere bürste mit rein da meine silikon
bürste weil alles andere ist ziemlich
unhygienisch finde die kriegt man noch
schön sauber kann es auch immer schön
jeden tag desinfizieren und es zeige ich
euch jetzt hier mal
[Musik]
und wenn ihr euch selber einen toiletten
reiniger machen wollt mit dem er auch
wirklich urinstein kalk und ablagerungen
lösen könnt dann braucht im prinzip nur
ein gefasst wie der nato und
zitronensäure und etwas orangenöl das
orangenöl ist rein aus orangenschalen
hergestellt das ist meine bank ich habe
jetzt einfach immer eins im reiniger
schrank und ein bug schrank und das
nehme ich dann einfach keinen schönen
duft in dem jetzt hier nach 0 und
zitronensäure eins zu eins könnt ihr
euch schon auf vorrat herstellen und
draufschreiben das ist der wc reiniger
ist jetzt schon das aufbauschen öl mit
rein geben
[Musik]
man kann hier das pulver jetzt im
prinzip auch leicht mit wasser benebelt
und dann den eiswürfel formeln
eindrücken trocknen lassen habt ihr
spiel tabs also für das pc aber ich
lasse es gerne im glas ich kann so
einfach adressieren mal mehr oder mal
weniger nehmen
je nach bedarf und das ist wirklich auch
ein richtig toller reiniger
ich zeige euch hier den toiletten
reiniger mal nehmen jetzt einfach heißes
kochendes wasser
das kommt die toilette und dann vom
pulver einfach hinterher
[Musik]
er geht jetzt im prinzip mit meiner
toiletten reinigung weiter wie jeden tag
entweder nämlich einige oder einfach
desinfektionsmittel sprüht alles schön
ein
und ich nehme dann immer toilettenpapier
dafür denn das kann ich dann einfach
wegschmeißen und habe keine tücher die
dann noch weitere bakterien hier in der
gegend herum streuen
zuerst einmal hier oben
[Musik]
ich muss dazu sagen dass wir beim
täglichen toilettengang mich soviel
toilettenpapier benutzen müssen denn wir
haben dusch wcs hier unten kommt dann so
ein strahl wasser aus blättern popo und
andere gemacht und ist mir auch wichtig
das zu erwähnen denn gerade bei kindern
erwachsenen da muss man halt mit wasser
sauber machen null-grad-marke guten
geschäft sowie sarah kernstadt gesagt
hatte wenn man irgendwie hundekacke hat
oder vom tor irgendwie angeschossen
wurde
macht man sich ja auch nicht einfach weg
macht mir am mittwoch sein werk smash
zweck und dafür brauchen wir eben beim
täglichen toilettengang nicht so viel
papier aber dafür benutzt die toilette
sauber zu machen jetzt nicht denken dass
wir voll die klopapier verbraucher sind
bei uns gleich sich dann wieder aus
richtung dusche
wir haben bei der dusche immer ziemlich
wenig kalkablagerungen denn wir haben
eine militäranlage also eine entkalkung
anlage finde ich auch ganz praktisch
weil man geht es weniger putzen muss was
wir auch nicht haben es mit glasboden
die hatten wir nämlich in der alten
wohnung und da war es halt echt immer so
da haben wir jeden tag wenn mal geduscht
haben immer das glas abgezogen damit
eben auch nicht schnell verkauft aber
natürlich muss man trotzdem die
armaturen immer wieder sauber machen und
bei der täglichen dusche nämlich auch
einfach mein handtuch oder ein tuch war
es eben quartals und trocknet dann alles
ab das habe ich jetzt heute noch nicht
gemacht wenn ich wusste ich werde jetzt
heute hier putzen wir beide in
duschköpfen wenn die ganz stark verkalkt
sind könnt ihr hier auch zitronensäure
wieder verwenden weil zitronensäure den
kalk löst bei neueren duschköpfen ist
aber so die haben mir diese gummilippen
und da kann man einfach wenn sie trocken
sind im finger drüber und eher kalt
lässt sich dann von alleine ab natürlich
muss man jetzt trotzdem muss sieht es
auch ganz gut noch mit zitronensäure
wasser drüber gehen
da werde ich jetzt kurz noch mal
in wasser erwärmen zitronensäure mischen
und hier schön alles ableiten
das ganze mache ich dann auch hier an
den wänden damit wirklich das ganze kalk
und gewaschen wird
und weil der dampfreiniger haben nämlich
auf den dampfreiniger gerade hier auch
beim abfluss den kann ich jetzt übrigens
mittlerweile auch schon sorge machen und
dann ist die dusche im prinzip auch
erledigt also einfach nur zitronensäure
und biss war
[Musik]
so leichte verschmutzungen und
verkannten lösen sich so echt wirklich
super und wenn es doch nicht weggeht
weil es schon länger verkauft es gibt
hier einfach noch ein bisschen
zitronensäure drauf last einblicken und
dann lässt sich auch mit wegwischen
[Musik]
hier sitzt erstmal alles sauber der
schwarm hat ausgedient der entsorge ich
jetzt und jetzt hole ich einfach nur ein
wischmopp und kann noch mal mit
zitronensäure wasser hier die fliesen
und sauber machen könnt ihr machen wenn
sie sehr verkauft sind ich mache mir
jetzt wir sind einfach und in den
dampfreiniger einem dampfreiniger komme
ich auch hier anstellen dran
die hier zum schwarm nicht so erreiche
und das mache ich auch regelmäßig weil
ich so alle ecken und kanten ausnutzen
kann und kann hier sogar noch in den
abfluss rein dampfen und dann ist auch
alles bakterien feiden der dampfreiniger
tötet durch den heißen dampf eben auch
99,99 prozent aller bakterien und dann
ist alles wieder sauber und rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt sind alle wandfliesen geputzte
jetzt geht's noch an die restlichen
oberflächen das heißt für mich spiegel
ganzes erstes waschbecken hier noch die
oberflächen die fenster
das mache ich eben mal schnell und ja
unfassbar gewalt gebracht die badewanne
ist bei uns nicht jeden tag im einsatz
daher ist auch nicht wirklich war kalt
denn nach der benutzung reibe ich sehen
wir gleich aus aber was natürlich bei
der badewanne passiert sie staubt
schnell ein
das heißt ich kann ich dann auch einmal
kurz aus reiben ich mache ich so ein mal
die woche ungefähr jeden tag muss ich
das auch nicht machen und dann ist die
badewanne auch schön sauber und wenn sie
doch verkalkt ist dann auch die bei der
dusche einfach etwas zitronensäure
verwenden und alica regierungsstellen
sauber macht den fenstern haben wir
plissees daran einfach als sichtschutz
das vom trügen keine ein gucken kann
hier einige ich jetzt einfach so nimmt
staubwedel und feuchtes tuch geht aber
auch mein uns letztlich schmutzig
selbstständig
dann kann ich jetzt hier schön von innen
und außen die fenster putzen erstmal die
rahmen an die fenster innen und daneben
außen
[Musik]
ich muss zugeben seit dem letzten
frühjahr haben wir das fenster nicht
mehr geputzt glaube ich so sitzt nämlich
aus aber man sieht halt nicht die
polizisten davon okay dann muss ich
jetzt wie katastrophal aus
[Musik]
fertig noch alle übrigen oberflächen
mission
[Musik]
ach komm ja spitze macht schon glücklich
oder denn mache nur eine kurze pause und
dann geht's an die waschbecken und an
den boden und dann bin ich fertig
gestärkt vom mittagessen geht es jetzt
weiter
ich werde jetzt hier noch alles was hier
staubig ist abgestorben dh sie leisten
die steckdosen hier bei uns das noch
diese wand geht jetzt auch ganz fix
[Musik]
damit ich jetzt hier am waschbecken da
nehme ich jetzt wieder meine natron
essig mischung einmal für den abfluss
und auch hier für den kalk richtig schön
zitronensäure und da mache ich jetzt so
ich habe hier noch mal wasser aufgekocht
der wasserkocher muss sowieso auch
gerade entkalkt werden
das heißt hier gebe ich jetzt reine
zitronensäure rein so kann ich den
wasserkocher entkalken und mit dem
zitronenwasser und zitronensäure was hat
dann eben hier noch schön alles sauber
bekommen
[Musik]
bei starken verkalkung und verschmutzung
könnte jetzt jeder zitronensäure nehmen
ich war am rand geben kurz einwirken
lassen und dann wegspülen
[Musik]
in dem becher haben wir unsere
zahnbürsten drin
und dem muss ich natürlich auch immer
wieder im alltag aus stühlen ansonsten
hat man da unten ganz wäre drin
hier gebe ich jetzt auch das
zitronensäure wasser rein und dann
ständig da auch gleich unsere
zahnbürsten rein denn die sind ja auch
gerne mal verunreinigt die köpfe die
wechsel ist sowieso die comeback
und gerade hier kann man das schon mal
hier eintauchen und schön sauber noch
alle anderen teile die gerne mal
verhalten könnt ihr mit dem
zitronensäure wasser saubere
[Musik]
die vorletzte tätigkeit ist fast immer
schön konnten nach vorne also von
unserem raum in den vorraum
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich am ziel angekommen der
letzte schritt ist jetzt boden wischen
meistens nämlich im alltag dafür einfach
etwas schmierseife da könnt ihr euch
gerne in einem reiniger video anschauen
wie ich meinen boden reiniger
zusammenmischen jetzt weil ich wirklich
gerade viele verschmutzungen habe
nämlich den dampfreiniger damit alles
wieder schön sauber und rein ist und
danach gibt es noch ein paar tipps und
tricks wie euer bad auch im alltag
richtig schön sauber bleibt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frühjahrsputz in bares bald fertig
den mülleimer habe ich jetzt auch schon
sauber gemacht und damit der immer gut
riecht nehmt ihr einfach auf orangenöl
gibt es auf etwas toilettenpapier und
das lege ich jetzt hier direkt und
irgendwann einmal rein und dann riecht
immer lecker nach orange wenn sich
darüber hier kommt jetzt wird er mein
kosmetik ein beutel rhein und die
restlichen beute
die kommen auch einfach hier und mit
rein so habt ihr immer eine tüte direkt
im anschluss dar wenn der volle
müllbeutel weg gebracht wird
menschen mit langen haaren werden wissen
wovon ich jetzt spreche wenn ich hier
dusche und meine haare geniere mich sehr
aus danach kommt noch ein bisschen
spülung rein oder hak uhr und dann kommt
es oft vor dass meine haare einfach
ziemlich ausfahren und befeuchtet dann
hier unten einfach ins in den abfluss
gießen lasse sammelt mich sehen also ich
kann meine haare immer so ein bisschen
mit den fingern durch
ich sammle die rare knuppe zusammenlegte
dann an den rand und schmeißt dann eben
nach der dusche einfach in den mülleimer
so verstockt da bloß nicht so schnell
und man spart sich eben auch enorm viel
zeit und das kann man wirklich täglich
bei der dusche einfach beachten
am waschbecken und in der dusche habe
ich immer mikrofasertuch liegen
so kann ich jeden tag nach dem
zähneputzen nach dem händewaschen
einfach kurz darüber reiben so könnt ihr
im alltag nämlich wirklich alles schön
sauber halten
entweder liegt es direkt abzog oder ihr
versteckt so ein bisschen wenn das tuch
nicht ganz so schön ist und am besten
ist es aber wirklich wenn ihr könnt euch
eine bwt anlage ein also eine
enthärtungsanlage so habt ihr schon von
grund auf kaltes wasser und es entstehen
erst gar nicht so wie kalkflecken
abends oder morgens nach dem zähneputzen
sich übrigens auch gerne mal die zeit um
auszumisten und dinge weg zu räumen die
hier nicht rein gehören hatte wenn ihr
sowieso grad wirkung steht und zähne
putzt und euch im watt bewegt dann räumt
einfach schon mal als weg alle kleider
die er nicht mehr braucht last nichts
herum liegen und dann bleibt er bat auch
im alltag immer schön sauer
also ich würde sagen im alltag putze ich
wirklich schon relativ viel so während
ich mich fertig machen und wenn ich dann
meinen wöchentlichen bad putz mache
brauche ich ungefähr eine dreiviertel
stunde bis stunde die fenster habe ich
ja jetzt nicht jedes mal dabei oder auch
die fliesen an der wand von daher geht
es wirklich super schnell
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
wenn ihr noch fragen habt schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare
so taucht ein bad putzen hat und wir
sehen uns wieder beim nächsten mal
und mama hat feierabend
[Musik]
tschüss